hi I'm Erik Bosse in spider-man far from
homes biggest mystery other than the
insanity of Peter Parker and Nick Fury
coming back from the dead it's this
mystery yo Mysterio what is this guy's
feel is he a hero why do there appear to
be several other new villains in this
movie well a few new details have
emerged from this footage so let's dig
deeper into the villains of spider-man
far from home and spoil there weren't
any kissing anything right or life okay
so we're pressure on Mysterio played by
Jake Gyllenhaal named Quentin Beck job
former Hollywood special-effects artist
known for his fishbowl style helmet
over-the-top costume and illusions now
he doesn't use real sorcery
he's more magician than wizard unless
you're a magician then all of your
wizards Beck uses practical movie style
special effects you know smoke and
mirrors sometimes that smoke is toxic or
hallucinatory that's the helmet and for
many of us mirrors are toxic in the
hallucinatory mysterio is also at times
presented himself as a hero solving
crises that he actually created
defeating these fake villains that were
actually illusions under his control
were villains that were actually him in
disguise and that some believe is what
Mysterio could be doing in this movie in
the breakdown I did at the trailer I
pointed out how all of Mysterio's
actions are so theatrical he's like a
guy at comic-con who couldn't decide if
he wanted to cosplay as Thor Iron Man or
Doctor Strange so he's like you know
what I'll do all three though look at
those mystical shapes of his energy
beams at first they kind of look like
dr. strange mystic spells what have you
looking at more closely you can see that
they originate from sparks that come out
of his gauntlets as if these are
practical pyrotechnics yeah yeah we're
seeing that zipper Mysterio so does that
mean that this water Monster is actually
an illusion under mysterious control if
so that's a very impressive stunt water
bending ain't easy
like imagine Quinton wading down into
the canal at night installing hundreds
of water jets magic is my life but it's
not totally clear that this exactly is
the case because it turns out this far
from home trailer hid three cryptic
Easter eggs one of them we already
pointed out and I break down the shot of
students touring venice behind ned you
can see a boat with the letters a sm 2
and 2 that could be a nod to the comic
amazing spider-man issued 212 which was
the introduction of the villain
hydro-man Hydra man is Morrie bench a
crew man on a cargo ship who got knocked
into the ocean while an experimental
generator was being tested on the water
giving him the ability
transform into water himself he's really
a lesser-known Spidey villain but he has
shown up in different incarnations of
the sinister six
like the sinister syndicate from the
universal ride that I went on a bunch as
a kid there was another similar Easter
egg in another shot in this trailer with
Nick Fury and Maria hill firing guns at
a different monster this one made of
dirt rock and rubble but look at that
license plate it's partially covered but
you can make out for 63 that could be a
reference to the amazing spider-man
issue 4 which came out in 1963 it was
the introduction of the villain Sandman
Sandman is Flint Marko an escaped
criminal who runs into a nuclear testing
site on a beach causing his molecular
structure to fuse with that of sand he's
a much better known recurring Spidey
villain you may remember him from the
Sam Raimi spider-man 3 but if that was
enough this far from home trailer hid a
3rd Easter Egg in the footage of the
Tower Bridge scene in London the
students run past an audio with the
license plate number 2865 SCP 2865 could
be a nod to the amazing spider-man issue
28 released in 1965 this was the
introduction of molten man molten man
like Hydra Man is a lesser-known villain
he's mark Roxton a former scientist for
Oscorp
he stole a liquid metal alloy from a
radioactive meteor hoping the sell it
but then after a fight the alloy spilled
on him and it gave him this golden
metallic skin but it also gives off
uncontrollable levels of heat molten man
could be the figure that we see right
before this part of the trailer fiery
metallic looking figure that bursts from
a meteorite looking cocooned structure
so all of this is pretty good evidence
that in addition of Mysterio Hydra man
Sandman and molten man or some versions
of them could be in this movie why so
many villains though there are a few
ways that I could see this going one
Theory perhaps far from ohm is
retconning the backstory of these Spidey
villains so that they're actually just a
cast of patsies in Mysterio's grand
false-flag strategy each one
representing a different natural element
water earth fire calling themselves
villain names like Hydra man Sandman
molten man names given to them by mr.
Hollywood himself Mysterio creating this
easily digestible scenario where he gets
to play hero now it's also possible that
each of these forms could be played by
one collaborator of Mysterio's there was
a report that Turkish born actor Neumann
a car would be playing a part in this
movie as a
guy named dmitri which was the first
name of the spiderman villain demetrius
murder cove AKA the chameleon now in the
comics chameleon is more of a master
disguise and doesn't have these kind of
shape-shifting abilities but maybe the
movie will feature him and Mysterio is
part of a duo of actors and
special-effects dudes staging these epic
duels a european tour of street theater
with Gyllenhaal as a pretty boy
receiving all the superhero praise now
sure that might feel a bit like the
twist that we saw in Iron Man 3 remember
the one that revealed the Mandarin is
nothing more than a false identity
played by a patsy actor I guess it all
depends on how sacred you consider flint
Marcos backstory to be that'd be kind of
a nerdy cross to dialogue the VidCon
Sandman literally sand models so they
grew up making now there's also the
possibility that these sub villains are
based on the elementals an ancient group
in the Doctor Strange comics hydron
master of water magnum master of earth
Hellfire master of fire and Zephyr
master of air something in the Econo
artists really wanted to expose a lot of
her skin to looking closely that tower
bridge attack those bolts of lightning
definitely appear to be targeted we
could be looking at a fourth air or
weather or electricity based villain
maybe Zephyr or maybe another element
based Spider Man villain like electro
whatever names they go by or whether
they're autonomous or being controlled
by a central mastermind I do not think
these other things will be major
villains on par with Mysterio the way
Sandman venom and Harry Osborn goblin
were in spider-man 3 we already have a
plethora of villains in spider-man's
world
remember the post-credits scene of
homecoming hinted that Adrian Toomes
vulture and Mac Gargan a scorpion would
come back at some point so I predict the
multiple villain team-up will be coming
in the third of these spider-man movies
the true sinister six movie that we've
been promised like imagine a
post-credits scene in part from home
Adrian Toomes and Mac Gargan still in
prison Quentin Beck maybe also his
partner Dimitri also incarcerated but
they're all released by one man Norman
Osborn rebooted in them see you or maybe
Doc Ock maybe a member of this version
of the sinister six could be the
incarcerated Cletus Kasady
bringing carnage into the MCU I know it
feels like kind of a stretch but hey
every crew needs a psycho who goes too
far and homecoming in part from home
spider-man has been more of a pest
interfering in villains plans but I
think in this third movie which
could be called something like
spider-man homefront these villains will
finally band together to deal with this
pest figure out who he is and strike
them right at home but I want to know
from you guys what do you want the
post-credits scene is spider-man far
from home to be comment down below
follow us and subscribe to our new
podcast where ever you listen to
podcasts especially if used the Himalaya
app because subbing through Himalaya
will help them help us release new fun
shows and if you live in the LA area
come see my live comedy show darkest
timeline comedy starring me some
hilarious comedians I know some guests
from new rock stars so you know and love
Friday February 1st at the Acme theatre
in North Hollywood thank you for
watching and hey if Sandman really was
your favorite Sparta man villain I'm
sorry to make fun of you you're right
sand is scary it's a coarse and rough
and irritating and it gets everywhere
[Music]